- [Voiceover] Hello grammarians!
I want to talk about personal pronouns.
But before I get too specific with that,
I just want to write out
some sentences for you.
Now, all of these words
that I'm about to circle,
"I," "we," "you," "you," and, "they,"
are personal pronouns.
We decide which personal pronouns
are appropriate for a given sentence
depending on whom we're talking about.
I'll explain.
In English, we divide personal pronouns
into three basic types.
There are pronouns that are about me.
There are pronouns that are about you.
And there are pronouns that are
people or things that
are neither me nor you.
Another way of saying this is
that this is the first person,
the second person,
and the third person.
Another way to divide up these pronouns
is to divide it into
the singular and the plural.
The one,
and the more than one.
So in English,
if we're only talking about
one person that includes me,
well, then we'd be talking
about pronouns like,
"I," "me," "my," and, "mine."
But if I am in a group
of two or more people,
we don't refer to ourselves as, "I."
We refer to ourselves as,
"we," or, "us," or, "our," or, "ours."
And if I were talking about you
or something that belonged to you,
whether it was singular or plural
I would say, "you," "your," and, "yours."
So when I said, "You
are a capable person,"
and I said, "You are capable people,"
I was trying to demonstrate that
"you" is the same,
whether it's singular or plural.
Whether there is one person in "you",
or more than one person.
In standard American English,
there is no difference between
just one person and multiple people
when you're addressing them directly,
in what we call, "the second person."
So if we're talking about people or things
that are neither me nor you
when there's only one of
those people or things,
we would refer to that person or thing as,
"she," "her," "hers," "he,"
"him," or, "his," or, "it," and, "its."
Now if we're talking about more than one
person or thing that
is neither me nor you,
then we would say,
"they," "them," "their," or, "theirs."
Now there is most certainly
a way to distinguish
between, "I," and, "me,"
and, "my," and, "mine."
For the meantime, just
take a look at this chart.
Pause the screen if you have to.
Maybe practice saying them out loud
and figuring out which one
corresponds to which box.
If I say, "it," is that in the first,
second, or third person?
Am I talking about me, you,
or a person or thing that
is neither me nor you?
If I talk about "them", am
I talking about me or you
or people that are neither you nor me?
Give it a try,
check out the exercise,
we'll go deeper in the next video.
You can learn anything.
David out.